-Welcome. Welcome back
to the show.
This is your first time
in the studio.
-First time in the studio, yeah.
I was in Zoom last time.
-Yeah, but a lot of great things
have happened to you
since our interview.
-Yeah, lots happened.
-You won an Oscar.
-I did win an Oscar, yeah.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-You were fantastic in that.
You're great in everything, man,
but also got to host
"Saturday Night Live."
-I did host
I loved it.
-Dude, how --
you were telling me
that you were obsessed
with Kenan Thompson.
-Yeah, I wrote a play
when I was 9 years old,
and I won a competition.
It got performed
at [speaks indistinctly]
And it was based
on "Kenan & Kel."
And it --
-And there you were,
you got to meet and work
with Kenan.
-Kenan, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was amazing, it was amazing.
-He's the best, too.
-Yeah.
-Have you ever met him before?
-I saw him on the street.
Like, it was Halloween.
It was Halloween.
I saw him on the street,
and he was in the line.
I go, "That's my boy,
that's Kenan."
And "Oh, you should go up
to him."
And I was dressed as Batman,
so...
[ Laughter ]
"Hey. Hey, Kenan."
"How you doing?"
-He goes,
"Oh, I remember meeting you.
Yeah, you're Batman, yeah."
Did you guys get to do
any sketches?
-No, yeah, but we did --
I think a couple.
I think a couple, but then
the first time I met him,
I was like -- there was a sketch
that was like --
they were just trying out,
and, like, I was scatting.
Like, doing, like,
a jazz skit -- sketch.
And it was like --
So the first time I met him,
I was scatting.
[ Scats ]
-Yeah.
-He was just like, "What?"
I was like, "Yeah."
-I love that you're Batman
and then Scatman.
-Then Scatman.
[ Laughter ]
-I got to ask you about this.
Everyone's probably asking you
about this.
Probably tired of answering,
but you're not going to return
in the "Black Panther,"
in the sequel.
-No. No.
-No. That's sad for us,
'cause we like you.
Was that a tough decision?
-It was, it was, it was.
Schedule conflicts with "Nope,"
and I couldn't make it work,
couldn't make dates work,
but the film's gonna be amazing.
-Yeah.
-It's gonna be amazing.
-It's gonna be good.
Oh, so you were shooting "Nope,"
and you were like, "Can't."
-It just clashed.
-You're too -- You're wanted.
Too many people want you.
-I know.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-It's not a problem, is it?
-It's not a problem at all.
[ Both speaking at once ]
-Yeah. But what --
can we see you come back
in the Marvel Universe?
-I mean, yeah.
-Yeah.
-He's around, isn't he?
-Right.
-He went to -- I don't know.
He went to Uganda for a trip.
Instead of Wakanda, yeah.
-He went to Uganda?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll see him pop up somewhere.
Yeah, you've been doing, also,
a lot of work
behind the scenes with your
company 59% Productions,
which I think I understand
the reference on this.
59%.
-It's the win rate
of "Moneyball."
-"Moneyball."
-The Oakland A's team.
I'm obsessed about the book
and the film,
and I read the script
and I read the book, everything.
And it's the win rate,
and it's the win rate
of all my favorite managers,
my football managers,
that I love back in the day.
-59%.
-59%. So that's championship
winning looks like -- 59%.
-Exactly. I love that.
Well, didn't you just finish
your first film
that you --
-That I wrote.
-That you wrote?
-Yeah, yeah. I co-wrote a film
called "The Kitchen." I've been
writing that for 10 years.
10 long years.
-It's based on "Kenan & Kel."
[ Laughter ]
-Kenan's got a cameo.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No, it's set in a dystopian
future of London.
It's about the working class.
-How cool is that? You get to
make your dream a reality.
-Yeah, I'm so blessed.
I'm like -- I was on set,
I was just so happy.
I was on set every day,
just making --
I love making stuff, so.
-Yeah.
Let's talk about "Nope,"
whatever we can talk
about "Nope,"
'cause I know it's Jordan Peele,
who we love.
We had Jordan on
when he was funny Jordan.
[ Laughter ]
-He's not funny, he's sad.
-He's sad now, yeah.
-He's sad. He's rich, though.
-He's rich.
[ Laughter ]
-But he's sad.
That's how it works.
-You get rich, you get sad.
Exactly right, man.
But so I don't want to give
too much away,
and I know you just had
the premiere,
so some people are already
talking about it.
I'm not looking online
at anything.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I just cannot wait, man.
-When are you watching it?
-I'll watch it this weekend.
-Watch it this weekend.
-Should IMAX it, right?
-Yeah, IMAX. Definitely IMAX.
-If you can.
-It's amazing on IMAX.
-Yeah, if you can see it
in the IMAX,
do it in the IMAX.
But can we say about it?
Who's Keke Palmer playing?
-Keke Palmer plays --
I can say that --
she plays my sister.
-Okay.
-She plays my sister
in the film.
-Brother and sister.
-Brother and sister,
and we own a ranch.
-Okay.
-And --
-A ranch?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What happened?
What happened?
-Dip it in ranch.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Ranch is a big deal over here.
-Okay. Yeah, no, I get that.
Late at night,
I always order wings.
Like, I'll go out
and order those wings,
and they're like,
"Ranch or blue cheese?"
-And you go, "Ranch, hello."
-Ranch.
-Dip it.
-I be like, "Ranch!"
-You're like, "Dip it."
[ Laughter ]
"Ranch!"
-"Ranch, please, now!"
-Yeah.
So you guys own a ranch.
[ Laughter ]
That's just so weird.
We're talking about it.
Sorry, so you own a --
And then something happens,
and we don't really know
what's happened.
-Something happens
to their father,
and then it leads to them having
to discover a new reality.
-Can we say why is it called
"Nope"?
-'Cause Jordan and I --
Jordan was speaking to me
about the film,
and then, for whatever reason,
he was developing,
and I was like,
"What's it called?" I had never
asked him what it was called.
He said, "Nope."
-And I laughed for 30 seconds.
Like, that was so funny.
'Cause he said that's
the reaction
that Black people will have
when they watch it.
Like, they're like, "Nope."
[ Laughter ]
"Nope."
I was like, "Yeah."
-"Nope."
-I was like, "Yeah."
-[ Laughs ] That's funny.
-Yeah, yeah.
-See, Jordan Peele
still is funny, man, yeah.
-Yes, he is.
-He's funny as hell.
That's really good, yeah.
Look at it and go, "Nope.
Not for me. I'm out."
Alright, well, I want to show
everyone a clip.
This is not giving
too much away, right?
But this is a clip
of Daniel Kaluuya in "Nope."
Take a look at this.
-What did you see?
Hmm?
-It was big.
-How big?
-Big.
-What'd it look like?
-I don't know.
-[ Sighs ]
-It was fast.
Too fast.
Too quiet to be a plane.
-OJ, are you saying
what I think you're saying?
-Ooh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Daniel Kaluuya!
"Nope" is in theaters and IMAX
this Friday.